to see we're both awake
I am not don't you feel like the day you
should just have nap times yes built
into them I've been nabbing the last two
days hey it's Justina
this guy we have made so many videos
together in the past if you haven't
checked out Rose Channel be sure to do
so I'll put all of her links in the
description but today Roe I brought
something very very fun this is Hot
Wheels Rift rally so basically this
comes with a car because iPad or
Playstation anything awesome reality
this car will be driving around and
you'll be able to see the traffic on
your PlayStation it's so cool okay guys
I'm gonna be honest 100 Justine
explained to me what augmented reality
was because I was very confused I mean
I'm sure you've experienced augmented
reality like things like Pokemon go
where you're not necessarily taking
yourself out of the world it's sort of
just adding things to the world so
virtual reality headset you can't see
anything else right like you have the
Oculus on you're in a totally different
space I've done that and I didn't
realize that augmented reality was like
we're putting things in your reality so
we're gonna turn your house into a Hot
Wheels track oh my gosh I'm just so
excited me too okay let's what kind of
card do we get I don't know there's all
these cars on the box how do you know
which one we get well because you can
actually make your car look however you
want in the game
yeah so the car will look one way to you
but then so ours is gonna look like like
a clunker a robot and then we can pick
in the game what it looks like yeah
this is like a big shoe box so we need
to download the app so I'm gonna be
playing this with my iPad here's our car
bad looking no just like really cute
there's a little camera oh my gosh
that's amazing you may have seen they
came out with a Mario Kart version of
this as well so it's a very similar
thing
but now it's for Hot Wheels we've got
all kinds of little accessories we've
got a charging cable look at this yeah I
don't know what those are yet what are
these are these stations or laps we're
gonna find out we don't know I got
lipstick on your box oh that's okay oh
it's just gonna drool all right what
else do we got here
signs oh it drives under it I don't know
yet oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oh I did it
oh
these go on the bottom
look at our checkpoints
we are set so now we're gonna download
the app and then we gotta connect our
car to it
whoa
whoa so cute your chameleon is the last
car you'll ever need because it can
simulate the look and feel of any other
person we can make this look like
anything I love it so it's gonna change
its characteristics based on which one
we pick yeah whoa let's browse the cars
so it looks like none of them are
unlocked yet oh wait they're gonna give
us some bits to start our collection I
like when it gives you things he turns
green like he's like I'm generous look
what we got this is the bone shaker I
love it it's so nice I think we're ready
to play I'm ready okay the campaign map
each node on the map is a challenge okay
we gotta point the car towards this QR
code we've got a full battery okay we're
establishing your connection launch
activity so how we gotta set up some
stuff oh my God he's moving oh geez look
whoa what a messy room whoa we gotta set
these look you can see
look there's our car this is cool you
guys so in person this is cardboard
right but in the game it's like this
cool look at this you set it up
I know maybe we'll just take it for a
quick swim here and see what happens
okay here we go oh I can't wait okay
okay go ahead and drive and get the feel
of it
oh my gosh you drive it from this yeah
okay okay so here we go
oh
it's going it's going okay he's going
straight well we can go straight oh
sorry that's okay
at your face
can you see if I have anything in my
teeth from lunch Justine it's turned red
is this he's mad he's mad I don't like
that okay okay we got it we gotta
reconnect him
okay so we figured out the mechanics now
I think we need to make a little track
there's a loop around my living room the
loop okay let's do it
so we've got our track all set up and I
also customized the car you can add
different color appearances to look at
this we can do different colors
oh me too oh yeah then we also have
performance so you can tune different
stats so I have turned the top speed all
the way up in our acceleration yep
our car there it is here we go okay so
yes if you tap
there it is okay got a point perfect
here we go for number three go a little
car
oh my gosh the dogs are losing their
mind okay so it does go over carpet wow
this is fun okay here we go through
number four yes yes and you can see the
dogs losing them in the office they're
so excited we go back through number one
okay do you wanna try it yeah okay this
goes and this turns uh watch the screen
don't watch the car don't watch the car
oh no Justine I missed the checkpoint
Mike open your
Mike open your legs
Michael move your foot Michael Michael I
can't get through I'm like oh you you
stepped in front of me I think
oh shoot wait reverse reverse yep okay
okay it's saying hold gas and break gas
cannot be able to do that when you're
driving don't get them both at the same
time okay I'm gonna try it ready okay
oh whoa it revs it all up let me back it
up okay
there we go whoa oh my God he's going so
fast
it's going so fast
oh we're good we're going
I love that we're doing this like a tag
team now like you're you're driving
this is so fun I'm full speed okay now
when we turn around this quarter when we
get to one let's do the gas and break
again okay always ready
right after we go through here okay yeah
one two
oh I think we did a pretty good job
let's see if there's another activity we
can do
we did all of this already we're ahead
of we're ahead of it so
oh my gosh look how cute this is
okay so we're gate one we're ready oh
you know what I have to do okay ready
okay here we are
this is epic drive through the gates and
order the path you take will be the
track for upcoming races and challenges
so this is it's actually gonna be our
track now
it's all different colors and it's like
you're breaking glass when you're like
driving through them
[Applause]
I love it
here's gate four
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay look at the
oops oh I just ran the more dude oh my
goodness okay okay so look up at the top
it's creating a track do you see it we
did it look at that that's so cool like
that's our track okay so now we're gonna
test out one of the courses so we
defined our track and the augment
reality as you can see it's turning all
of the different Gates into like
different themes oh no I'm not ready
Jesse you got this little support yes
yes here we go here we go here we go
look you got this oh
there's other people on our track
oh and I love it they have the outline
yeah back and they try to stay in it but
we'll see little bumpers oh my gosh
oh
[Music]
you guys oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
no no no no no no no
yes yes yes yes I'm trying so hard to
stay on the track
oh
oh man so close
I'm stressed you can catch him you can
catch him do you want to drive the last
one oh yeah this is Victory lap baby
Victory lap
I did everything
oh I missed time what happens when you
miss a game just keep going I think you
know what you just keep going yeah
you're just gonna keep you're doing very
well oh mama just pedals in the middle
I'm just hitting accelerate at this
point oh okay we're ready wait maybe
it's seven laps four of seven okay this
is an endurance thing this is endurance
oh yeah red car just pushed me because
we don't like I'm feeling kind of
offended
it's so funny how boring this looks in
person but it's so fun epic on the
action yeah it looks so cool
[Laughter]
this is my first race
finish finish we've done it we came in
second how did we come in second I don't
know we were honestly tragic I'm
actually really into this this is cool
because one of my favorite video games
is Mario Kart yes and it has some really
cool things that are similar there is a
Mario Kart version of this
yes are you kidding me no there's a
Mario car there's a Luigi car and you
guys can play together so it looks like
I know what I'm gonna be bringing over
next time I come over yes and let's set
up a track not on the carpet no no we're
gonna this is gonna be serious thank you
guys for watching don't forget to like
comment subscribe and be sure to go
check out Rose Channel and of course hit
the Bell to be notified when we post new
videos see ya bye I made a bell noise
for you that was so good A little sound
effect
[Music]
thank you